لم يحسم جدله اقاله الناظم الزهاوي من
منصبه في الحكومه ومن رئاسه حزب المحافظين
مع تعالي اصوات منتقده للاستعجال في فصله
من الحكومه واخرى معارضه للتاخير في فصله
من منصبه الوزاري رغم الوقائع ثابته
الاسئله تتزايد بشان طرد الزهاوي من
الحكومه بينما يتمسك ريش سوناك بانه تصرف
بشكل صحيح ونزيه بعد تحقيق مستقل في
ملابساته الضريبيه استغرق اسبوع فقط واخلص
الا ان الزهاوي خرق قواعد وزاريه
وما فعلته بمجرد علم بالقضيه هو تعيين شخص
مستقل للنظر في القمر
منصفا للتاكد من ان الحقائق
محددهم قال حلفاء لزهراوي ان لديهم خوف من
الطريقه التي جرى بها التحقيق والذي ادى
الى اقالته المعارضه وصلت توجيها سهام
انتقاداتها الى سوناك مطالبه بالكشف عن ما
كان يعرفه عن وضع هوي قبل تعيينه في
الحكومه في ما قضايا التنمر وتصرفات بعض
الوزاراء تلاحق مصداقيه ونزاهه سوناك التي
تعاهد بها لحظه اختياره مصطفى زارو
العربيه لندن